hello everybody i
am glad that you are here i hope that
we get to look at some of the amazing
games played by
adams in british championship that ended
recently
i believe on the fourth
i might be uh i might need to double
check my dates on that but
i know it's ended recently and uh adams
won it
i believe for the eighth time uh yeah
it's pretty amazing actually
so um two of his games
were particularly amazing to look at
just because
it wasn't that it was like a super cool
tactic it was more like it was a
perfect mix of tactic and
everything else so it was a great the
balance of strategy and dynamic so that
is
why i absolutely adored these games so
let's just go ahead and take good looks
let me also
open up a little bit of room for myself
over here
my desk is filled with pens books
and cuffs three tops god i need to
clean up the desk okay
yes this was the game that adam's played
versus
cox let me actually open this
a little bit more so it shows there we
go
this shows the names as well
all right perfect so
um to be honest this is not an opening
that i play
as black but i find it's very
interesting
so i think you guys will too
um in this opening in this setup opening
basically in this type of pawn structure
one thing that's very important is the
piece activity
which is usually an important thing in
any opening but in this one in
particular because
you see this bishop got activated pretty
fast so if you were to play e6 then you
would
always have an issue with this bishop
that's
one of the reasons why you should
consider
moves such as bishop f5 but at the same
time
especially in this pawn structures you
also have to be careful if there is a
knight on c3
let's say now black white played knight
c3 you go bishop f5
um e3 now let's say you
play some weird move like a6 now there's
going to be queen b3 attacking this
double
attack and it's not a very pleasant idea
for
whites for black so that's why i think
it's very important
to be cautious of these and to
make sure that you're always developing
the right piece not just getting your
pieces out
well to be fair a6 doesn't make much
sense but i was
trying to make a point about b3 queen b3
and attacking
this double pawns so all right
uh in the game e3 was played knight type
6
knight c3 bishop f5 a very similar
position because
this e3 has to be played this bishop
belongs here this light belongs here
this light belongs here
so there's not um it's not like a huge
surprise that
people played this anyways queen b3 was
played in the game
as i was just talking about the
potential of this double attacks now
um black to move
why do you think we should do as black
this tea is cold i will put it away so
i'll stop drinking
it this cough is also cold so that cup
has got
two oh my god now i have like four cups
next to each other it's a very scary
scene
oh it's exquisite j-mac peter i am glad
to see you guys have
showed up from the previous one
well be careful because if you were to
play v6
now this is what white wants that is the
idea behind queen b3
because now knight b f3 comes and now
there's this
other issue that's rising and you can't
just play e6 because bishop b5 and you
will lose this light
rook c8 is not enough protection knight
e5
see your bishop should have been like on
d7 or
b7 if you wanted to play this line
so e6
so sorry b6 is not a good choice what
else
yep we want to look for the best move
to be fair queen v6 is the second best
move
but take take and um rook c1 could just
go
a3 could just go it doesn't really go as
well as we wanted to
uh i wouldn't really go for that because
tag is attacking our knight as well
you can't just push because bishop b5
and yeah that's gonna be
painful
any other way to defend this pawn
i don't think you should sacrifice at
all not at this moment
you know what your opponent wants it's
just a matter of how to stop it
yep peter knight a5 good one j-mac
if check stop it queen moves away and
now what should you do you got to get
this bishop out but should you close it
should you play e6 and close this bishop
or what should you do
yep exquisite you are correct it is
either knight a5 or black is busted
anybody else what should black do
i don't think bishop f5 is the way to go
because if bishop goes to f5
well now there's bishop b5 check two and
what are you going to do bring back
you just wasted a bunch of moves and you
just gave your opponent
a bishop b52 knight goes to f3 now
knight wants to jump to e5
it doesn't make sense
yeah but now that you have your knight
on 85 and your bishop is looking towards
queensland you could just try to
organize your game in the queen
side so you don't exactly have to play
g6 g6 is doable
but again knight f3 bishop g7
um maybe just knight goes to e5 your
knight on a5 gets a little weird
so i think e6 is actually good enough
now it's just a matter of what to do
with this bishop
you have two choices where should we go
yeah i mean i generally think e6 is a
better choice if you don't
want to play e6 then you could think
about g6
but those should be your only two
options
you should go bishop b4 or you could
play rook c8 first too
then try to maybe get your pieces out
but the thing is
your game is in the queen side your
everything is pointing towards the queen
side so you might as well play there
anyways
so knight f3 get your bishop to b4
bishop d3 now um of course
castling is just as good as any other
move
but can you think of any better move or
just like a tiny bit more active
rca twin v6 both are doable anything
else
um so i don't think we should think
about knight h5 that's kind of
not doesn't really go with the flow of
our game
so i see you want to exchange a night
for bishop but i think you're thinking
about the wrong
nights oh oh gmp she's
making cat noises
there we go pc
i think the stray cat is behind the door
again
anywho um
what about this knight is this knight
good enough here can we do anything with
it
anyone because i'm thinking knight c4
it's a little unorthodox but it's like
next few moves one of them is cast all
one of them is rook c8
the other one is you gotta do something
with this knight um
so it's just a matter of which one to do
first
so actually it wouldn't harm our
structure because if knight c4
if you were to take it i would whoops
i would just take it back and that's
actually good because now we get to
actually push some pawns
and just try to you know kick your
knight over here try to go procedure
this is actually pretty good
then in the game um cox did not take it
uh he just played queen to e2
and adams played rook c8
as we were just talking about rook c1
now what do you think we should do and
yes
cast selling does work but it's not the
best choice
corbett
anything else besides castling that
could be interesting
i like the idea of b5 but not just yet
knight e4 yeah you got this yep nice
knight e4 and if you take it
i simply take back with the pawn
attacking your knight
you're gonna move your knight away and
to be fair i think knight g5 maybe was
not the best choice maybe not e5 would
have made it a little bit more
interesting
but even if not e5 i could simply
take over there take over there
[Music]
kick the bishop a little
and then you can simply just
start playing with your pawns
no i think that would be an interesting
choice
so all right let's go
back back back
what about knight g5
this is kind of funny i just got a
notification from quizlet
wouldn't say tink like a proton always
positive
that is so weird i was gonna say
cute dorky but it's just weird
all right so what about that g5 what
should we do about this knight
that's a good question i don't do you
need castle do you need to castle right
now
because well you have to be careful this
guy is under attack
knowing your pawn is under attack what
should you do
e5 not exactly but second best choice
what about f5
i kind of like f5 it directly protects
this i want to directly go attack your
stuff
no anyone good
well queen five doesn't really do much
because just g6 and then you have to
move the queen again
queen of e2 and
then h6 right night moves
push more pawns try to castle this is
kind of nice
pg agrees too
well after f5 in the game white flight
h4 i'm assuming
because castling was a little scary i
think
maybe um well h6 doesn't work let's
let's get that straight because now
that's what we make it three
um h6 doesn't work but you could just
bring up bring down the bishop attack
over here
and now if you move the knight you also
have to deal with
upcoming g5s not right away but
i could just relocate the knight a
little bit and then plan for g5
so i think that's something to be aware
of
so
now um in the game h4 was played which i
think was
the first uh mistake that white means
now what should we do as black keep in
mind still h6 doesn't work
um queen f6 maybe but the problem with
queen f6
is that maybe just a3
is a little agitating but again you
could just take that too
no i think you're good either way
we could also rewrite it that is true
but
well i think the thing with h4 is that
let's let's ask ourselves a question
white's playing in king's side we don't
really
we're not really worried about that but
we shouldn't push too much in the king
side if we can't
so we're pushing in the queen side so
how can we continue this push in the
queen side
anyone feels like we can push more there
ah b let's push the b
now if you cast them i will happily
castle as well
now it's time to start kicking this
knight because there is no more queenish
5 checks
so in the game white flight b3 kicking
my knight
now where do you think this knight
should go
and peaches is still making his cute
little noises
is she
well you could you could simply
[Music]
you could simply bring this knight back
and try to go to d5
but be careful because if you go back to
b6 you
you could you would kind of have to deal
with takes
and not that it's such a big problem
because you would have knight d5 and
your knight is like a god over
here alright got this
oh that's a good question though we can
solve this question later on
um but taking over here on c8
take back i mean why is black is doing
all right much
much better than i would dream of
for most of my d4d5 life
but another idea that i've learned from
roy lopez this idea with knight a3
it doesn't do much but it really bugs
the opponent so i like that
knight a3 and in the game white played
queen b2 which was not the best move
now can you tell me what do you think is
the best move for white
there is one move that is kind of
interesting
for whites does give it a little bit of
advantage
hello
anybody can tell me what do you think is
best move for white
no not exactly queenish vibe so you're
you don't really have much to do in the
king side
anyways you should try to do something
in the center as white because that
knight is kind of stuck up on a3
knight b1 is doable i think knight b1 is
the second best move
but the best one is something in the
center such as d5
surprisingly because now if you were to
take over here
take on e6 now what do you want to do
with your bishop you go to e8
now just attack attack attack left and
right this would make for a very
interesting game compared to what went
down over the board which is kind of
a little ironic
and if d5 you were to take it twelve
thousand knight takes and this is like
plus
three or four for white because what do
you want to do with your bishop and your
knight here is looking a little bit
weird
like you really what do you want to do
with the knight
sorry with the bishop like go to a5 pull
just bishop d6 and these
knights this bishop it's gonna be i i
wouldn't want to play as black
exactly so you could play e5 if bishop
tanks queen e7
and then if something like f4 poisson
take with the knight this is another
doable position for white
and black would but white has a little
bit more activity
and if i give you weird looks in the
cameras because i have a very cute cat
right behind it and it's kind of staring
me down it's a little scary
i already got your amazon subscription
peachy
should be here by monday
it does have his own amazon subscription
uh e5 is doable but the thing is with d5
white would gain a tiny bit of advantage
which is kind of fun because over here
it kind of looks miserable if you don't
play d5
which white didn't white simply play the
defensive moves such as queen b2
it's not a bad move you're defending
your knight you're attacking this knight
but um
what do you think should happen
what do you think we can do as black
keep in mind this queen could have some
stuff in my queen's king's line
and it just moved away so what does that
give us
oh
is she coming for the microphone i'm
gonna gently move the microphone away
you all remember how that went from
tuesday
garbowsky will be
let me sit down quickly
okay so i think the idea of bishop c3
is definitely doable but not really the
way to go because this queen just moved
away so let's go h6
and go after this knight and now when
you move your knight away i'm just going
to eat this pawn
just simple chess
no need to worry too much about it
and in the game white now realized
now white was kind of late to the party
and now he played d5
which is wrong and i want you to tell me
why this is wrong
but the main point being that
it's kind of sad because white did find
this idea of d5
just a little bit too late about
two moves
if you play two moves that go to d5
white would actually hold a tiny bit of
advantage
queen f6 is the best one yeah i am
i'll bring another attacker towards this
poor guy
and in the game white plays knights d1
how can how can you continue how can you
win this and yes there are multiple ways
easiest one you could just take over
here take back
and ah it's a lot of non-night moves and
then take the pawn
it would be like what three two pawns up
in a simpler aimed game that is one of
the easiest way to win
anything else
yeah taking the rook is also a great
idea you take back
and now i can just play rook c8 and
fun funny enough white just resigned
over here
because if queen b2 i can just simply
take that
take over here and your pieces are just
miserable
rook d rook c2 also coming up you play
rook d1 g5 you move this bishop away
bishop e6 just defending it
and this knight is just crying this
light over here is crying like a lot of
crying pieces
so actually blacks dwight just resigned
over here after rook c8
so i think i thought this was actually
such a crushing game
yeah all right
anybody questions on this game or should
i move on to the next one
okay so there was another game that i
found pretty amazing
um this one again adams was
black
there are normal openings not much to
talk about
it's just i don't really think
there is anything wrong with these lines
i gave chromefeld a little try i liked
it
not exactly my thing i really like these
ideas with like knight f3 b5
and b6 and i tried those a little bit
those are also fun too
um so
there is this is just normal ready um
trying to be king's gambit sorry king's
indian
and um taking on d5 now we have
somewhat of a reverse moroxy pawn
structure that i
am a very big fan of now
what do you think white sorry now black
um a lot of you might play this
some of you might not i don't play this
line as black but i
have an understanding of where my pieces
should be
so my question to you is now it is black
to move
where do you think your pieces belong so
just try to tell me like
this bishop should be there this knight
should be there
this rook should be there because i
think that could help you a lot
in understanding a lot of the positions
that you don't play
um anyone want to give me a hint on
where the pieces belong over here
best way or books to learn openings
um for openings i i tried to be inspired
by looking at different games
and that kind of helps me figure out
what really goes with my style
for example i gave korokon a try it
doesn't really go with my style i gave
niner of a try
it went better with my style but i
didn't have enough time to learn
it so i started to just play around with
it um
like i generally like to fiance on my
bishop so i found
like a lopez line that i can do that
with um
i can't exactly do that with italian so
italian you just kind of
i try to find the best player that
some of the best players that play those
lines and just kind of combine them and
see what they play
but yeah that is generally true yep so
rookie 8 is the way to go
rookie 8 you're kind of um just a
classic thing to do you're stopping any
anything coming up for your e5 you might
want to play a bishop g4 later
maybe not you might want to play bishop
f5 uh you might simply want to relocate
this knight so you have
more exposure on d3 uh you might want to
bring that that bishop to the other side
so there's a lot of different ways to go
in the game white point knight c4 black
goes for bishop f5
just going after this fish this pawn
knight g5
and now what what do you think we should
do
pc he's kind of stalking me a little bit
and he's under the table kind of playing
with my toes
which is cute but a little bit creepy oh
he's bored he wants
to play he's playing with a ribbon now
it's kind of cute
i like how cats are independent and when
they they come play with you but when
you
don't have time to play with them
they're like okay i don't need you i'm
gonna go play with myself
but at the same time he's kind of
sitting around kind of staring at me
waiting to pounce hello
so what do you guys think
yep you got to move the knight first
yeah you got right
so where should you go with this knight
that's kind of a big question
i took my pin out um
knife b6 yep
you're very good exquisite yeah an ip6
best one
going after this knight if you were to
take it now this is even better for me
because i opened up
some lines now i have stuff defending my
other
weak potential weaknesses d3 is super
weak i love it
so after an ip6 white played queen b3
and now after queen b3 what do you think
we should do
as black this move
made me a little um just hot
but it makes sense it just didn't make
sense to me immediately
so if you if it doesn't make sense to
you either that's perfectly fine
um taking on d3 careful because
f7 is what queen b3 is going after so if
you were to simply take over here in
knight b6 and you are gonna get busted
my friends
so you have to somewhat protect this
pawn my thought was knight c4 is the
straightforward way and then you would
just do queen c7 if you take over here
i'll just
i can take there or i can play like h6
you move this knight
and then i'll take there i thought this
was the most straightforward way which
is which it is actually it is okay
but the best uh like if you wanted to
still like
be a little bit tricky um
rook e7 is the way to go so you're
defending you're defending
you're defending everything but at the
same time
i thought e7 knight e4 with idea bishop
g5 might be a little questionable
and this was actually what happened in
the game
so now bishop wants to come to g5 we do
the logical thing of playing h6
um in the game white played knight takes
c5
now what do you think we should do
so
okay i see a lot of interesting ideas i
think um
i think the the one that would probably
stand out more to me is just rook c8
because you're kind of bringing more
stuff to go against this
this um i was going to say sack of
knights i don't know if that's the ward
but you're kind of bringing more stuff
to go attack this um
this knights that are kind of just like
just
there and like they're ready to be poked
so i kind of like that idea another
thing that you could do is simply take
on here
queen takes and then play rook c8 or
play like knight a5 these are all doable
but rook c8 is kind of trickier and the
idea is
if you were to play like knight t3 and i
could simply
move this bishop or um
we can't really take it because still
rook d1 exists on e4
still bishop before exists so that kind
of
stops it
but you could simply play now bishop e6
now another idea is this knight's d4
that's
it's a little um it kind of weirds me
out just a little bit
because well you're not really going to
take it because now
take and i'm attacking everything that
you have basically
um queen d7 and
a4 you just do like a bishop e6 or you
can just take over here
everything is under attack basically so
white would not have a pleasant time
but you don't really have to take it you
could just play queen to a3
and this is still under attack and this
is cylinder attack everything is still
kind of wobbly
i don't really like it i feel like it
would be a desperate try
i don't think we should be desperate
right now bishop v6 works fine why
shouldn't we do it
and if bishop v6 take take
now it's fine you have lost this pawn
but you have a lot of activity
ideally i would like to have my pawn and
have the activity
but this feels okay compared to the
desperate try of knight
d4 um
the problem here is that white kind of
caved white should have played this
bishop h3
and goes over winning in exchange but
white caved and white didn't
if white did this then yes black's
position would be
more uncomfortable than i would like to
admit
however in the specific position white
didn't do it and white played simply a4
now we have a little chance we have this
little
idea of running away from this um
exchange shish kebab
what should we do
so black to move basically how do we run
away from shish kebab
also uh fun fact shish kebab shishma in
far
and kebab you know you all should know
what kebab is well it's not kevlar it's
kevlar but still
it's like that little mini steaks that
you put in them
in a like in a grill but not exactly you
like
put them in one oh
um rotating yeah i need more english
give me a second to google that
oh
oh i need more farsi
well technically i have enough rc i need
more english
ah there we go ah skewer
there we go i kept thinking i knew that
all right that took me way too long to
explain anyways
thank you skewer
yes this should be fun
um so in the game
well bishop history would be painful but
we kind of dodged that bullet
uh careful because if you now take it
there is still bush of h3
there's also this a5 and now you got to
move this queen and there's a young rook
thief one
so um yeah rxt7 is the best one good job
you guys
or c7 you stop this you defend your b7
now you want to take on d3
um in the game white played a5 and
what do you think we should do as black
attacking our knight we have very
limited choices between d7 and c8 which
one do you think we should go
97 doesn't really do it for me because
if you played knight d7 now white can do
knight d5
you move your rook again rook c8 or
it doesn't really do its worry again
there's bishops trees it's just
uncomfortable
and i see it makes more sense because
you could try for new squares
yeah so in the game i played rick d1
defending this little guy
earth d6 let's go for it a6
b6 saving it we're not gonna take that
so we're not gonna activate our
opponent's pieces
uh queen b5 defend it up defend your
knights
knight defending this everything is
defending each other
b3 now what do you think we should do as
black
so to be fair b3 is not a bad move but
because you got to get this bishop out
somehow but it does give white
it does give black a little bit more um
freedom
all right i've seen you guys are
thinking about the idea e4 let's go for
it yeah e4
boom well actually hold on boom
now if y plays d4 now you can start
now you have a new square to jump into
and potentially a pipes to do not right
away but
potentially coming up knight d5
go after this knight go after this pawn
uh taking i think
was the smartest choice and just like
retrieving your queen going after this
guy
i think this would have been a better
choice but the problem is there's so
many weaknesses in white's position that
if white plays it
a little um a little unhap
a little a little um unprepared
then all these pawns can simply just
start flying off the board you take over
here
i'll just play rp5
or rook d7 and all these are still
flying off
so in the game black simply played f5
made more sense sorry sorry here f5
would be
it would make more sense as well instead
of knight a5 because if you play f3
now i could just um think
take some stuff over here maybe
this guy and that guy it's just so many
possibilities
yeah let me go back to the main position
here white
bishop d2 which was a mistake now we get
f5
f4 also coming up uh in the game of
black played sorry white played
bishop f1 trying to relocate let's not
worry about it let's just go up
no no pins for you today or c1 now we
take it
and now rook d5 attacking the queen
queen moves narrow
a5 trying to go to the other side and
that's
that's the beauty of this position
that's so amazing that we have this much
space that we can just fly around with
the rook
rook a1 now this is a very amazing move
that black does because
it's just one of those moves that you
don't have you don't think you need it
but when you see it you're like oh that
was so cute
and i'll give you guys maybe about 20
seconds to
think about it before i reveal it
kinda yeah this is like a very cool
leningrad
so no it's simply queen to g8 it's kind
of weird
whoops too fast because you are like
relocating your queen in like the
weirdest possible way
take on a5 you take back and you're
still bringing another one and you are
going to be able to
get this pawn because there's something
like b4 and now knight goes to c4 and
then b5 and that's
even worse for white than giving that
pawn
so that's why i think queen g8 is so
cool
queen g8 in the game why just play the
rook b1 because
the white was probably just like okay
you know what i'm just going to play
this rig b1
not even going to bother with the
activity of this line
and now we get 2k2
pressure pressure queen c4 queen c8
again pressure pressure pressure
pressure it's just amazing
uh queen b5 and now i saw this move of
knight b8
a little while ago and i'm gonna go
ahead and say whoever said it
nice idea i know it was a while ago but
you have the right idea because
you are relocating it you wanna i wanna
eat this fun
i really wanna eat this pond and they
came after rook a
um rook d2 was played which is
doesn't really go with my ideology but
also um adams has about 400 something
rating more than me so
i i think we can trust him on this just
a little bit
this idea of rook c3 would have been
amazing because
um if you're gonna give that exchange up
you might as well give it up in this way
now that you
are getting um even more counter play
however in the game rook d2 was played
nothing really wrong with it just not
the ideal way of giving up the exchange
because now this pawn is defended and
yes your knight gets activated
and yes this pawn is falling and all
those fun stuff but that would have been
the better way
okay so here white plays bishop c4
obviously activating the bishop
h5 now we're going from a different side
that's also one of other things that
i've seen
in most of the grand master games that i
try to kind of copy paste a little bit
is this idea of like whenever your
position is
stable and you don't really know which
side to attack oh sorry that's not the
right
when one side is a stable the other side
the oh
there's like always this h4h5 that kind
of really bugs me because for the
longest time i was just like
why did i keep doing this to me it's not
the serious weakness why are they coming
from a king with h5h4h4h5s
so anyways in the game white made a
mistake and played the move king f2
which is like
super weird if you want to save your
king you should go to h1 right you
should just
put the king into safety that was just
the oh
my god type of move we played
and um in the game
white played h4 which is totally fine
but not the best move
the best move would have been f4 opening
up your queen
right now if you were to take it whoops
now if you were to take it queen h3 and
then
bring out the bishop and that should be
a nice
check check
er or even well the thing is um
white does hold advantage for most of
the game so if you have to
do this f4 and activate your pieces and
get this perpetual nothing wrong with
that
but i can understand why you wouldn't do
that especially if you are
trying to win the title of the country
it may kind of i mean i can understand
you would want to keep more activity and
more pieces to play with
so h4 kind of makes sense but it's not
the move that the position
like it's not the best move of the
position so
after h4 queen d5 was played
kind of makes sense right trying to kind
of minimize your queen of activity
that is true watching horsing is
munching
oats on the wrong circus whoa that's
kind of true this horse gonna have to be
around here
well knight goes to a5 so you are not
totally off
just white made a mistake here by
playing queen e6
white should have played something like
rookie 2 maybe
to try to keep everything tidy
but white made a mistake and played
queen e6 which
is kind of a blunder because you could
probably i'm thinking can i just do rook
c4 and win this because
you can't take that because i just take
back
um anyways
even at two to twenty seven hundred
adams missed this rook c4 so it is fine
to miss tactics here and there
if you miss them every time then okay
that's questionable but
even a super grandmaster missed it here
he simply played queen c7
putting more pressure on the king side
rook g1
and he he finally took on c4 and now
white
black is actually better however instead
of rook g1
d5 would have made black much
um much more uncomfortable than he
should have been
rook g1 take take take and
now again white made a mistake and
played rook tree too
now as black we are doing our best this
rook here is just weird we have a good
file let's go for it and you go down
check i'll bring my queen attacking this
poor guy
and queen a2 now i'm gonna give you guys
a second
this position is already super winning
for black i just want to hear
what you think how should black finish
this off
yeah you could simply push this pawn i
think h3 is a good idea uh
h3 well you could also take on d4 it's
that good of a position because you
can't take as queen f3 checkmate
um so h3 also works or could you want
take take
check and go over there and you are
giving
different type of painful checks white
played something like king e2 you take
over here
and another check and just h2 and this
is becoming a queen
and white actually resigned here
yeah um i think this game was very good
just
especially both of these games that i
showed you in this hour was i think
pretty amazing because um they both kind
of go with the idea of pressure
and you saw that in the second game
adams was actually kind of worse
most of the game but he managed to find
activity he managed to find
um how to make his pieces better had to
use the space he had he missed bunch of
in
a bunch of the best moves anyways to a
2700
but it doesn't mean that he didn't play
good he just played better than his
opponents
and he played better chess
so he was very opportunistic and found
the moves that needed to be found
but yeah i kind of like this game this
these two i'm glad i managed to get
through both of them
rushed a little bit but glad i did
anyways
with that i am going to say goodbye to
you uh
make sure to check the schedule to see
who
and when we are streaming tomorrow
and for the remainder of the week
otherwise i will see you guys
on saturday for
twitch and on tuesday for
youtube and it's like a whole schedule
so just check it online this will be
much easier
all right have a great rest of your week
and